we had a royal drama
yeah and i'm already sick of you guys a
royal
wedding queen victoria is ready for her
big day
and a royal battle i had mentioned that
you think that i'm toxic and
manipulative
i do think you are those things and all
of it was not very regal at all
this is your the bachelor season 25
episode 2 recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and rose
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
oh and it was a royal mess of an episode
wasn't it a scandal and i mean that in
the best way possible what an
entertaining second episode of
the bachelor what did you guys think
this episode was very much about
queen victoria i got my crown
and i'm going to do my very best to not
speak in my
lady whistle down voice the entire time
lady
whistle down you do not know me
but it probably will come in and out
just like a certain celebrity who will
remain
unnamed accent did you guys follow that
i was hanging on every word
every word no matter how it was
pronounced
just don't be negative tomorrow guys and
queen victoria
really had me questioning and examining
what
royal regal crownly behavior
really is because while i think she is
very unbefitting of the crowd
the royal family has certainly had a
mess of its own haven't they
so we love it all bless this mess
now fill your chalices and let's
get to it we are starting out
jogging uh and i wrote down all these
workout shots of matt are really making
me feel like
i gotta go work out but that might get
in the way of my lying around time
i mean he's fit he's fabulous he's on a
peloton
yeah i gotta check the credits but i'm
pretty sure peloton
is probably a sponsor this season you
know we were really zooming in on that
logo
and now we're sitting here talking about
it so i guess it worked while matt
is working out solo the women are not
working things out together
yes they've all been brought to their
quarters at the nema colin
mansion um and i guess some of them
don't want to be
don't drink for every time someone is
anti-sorority
growing up i was not in a sorority i did
not have roommates i'm not here to
freaking be in a sorority we're not here
to be in a sorority
what's the problem with sororities i
certainly would rather be hanging out
with matt
i was in one made some of my lifelong
best friends there
i never understand the i'm not here to
make friends thing
um you can make a friend while dating
someone
but while they all are exchanging some
ugly words there was a beautiful amount
of champagne there so
cheers to that you can't make friends
with a person make friends with the
glass you know what i'm saying
to the macho we're starting to see where
the women will be living and
the clothes that they've brought which i
kind of love i mean we had chelsea in
that cute little fur coat
although then brie was tying her sweater
in a
in a way i did not understand i'm hoping
that the spark is there and that there's
there's instant chemistry what was that
it's not a seat belt why are we strapped
in is this a cool new trendy way of
tying a sweater and i just don't know
let me know in the comments below
brie love is an adventure
matt sobre gets the first one-on-one
date and of course we all have to say
how this is such a clear
advantage i feel like she has a major
head start
on everyone here but let's go now to
some different words words that are
queen victoria
seems to be struggling with i don't
think victoria understands the
definition of jealous
i'm not jealous i'm just like i will i
want that
nor seemingly of tail spin i'm not tail
spinning
i'm the only one that's being real but
cheers to this woman whose name i don't
know yet my name is jesenia
who is explaining maturity to victoria
i think it's just a matter of how
everyone copes with their emotions
differently
i'm very capable of still being happy
for someone else while dealing with my
own emotions
yeah you guys at first i thought that
the queen victoria thing would just be
funny and silly and over the top but
i'm pretty sure she's the villain the
stuff she was saying was me
i think the girls that are happy for
bree are all faking
lady whistle down would not approve of
this behavior
at a social event in the season can the
ends
ever justify such wretched means
oh we're like really in a season like in
bridgeton they were in the season
of finding a match and we're in the
season of finding a match oh my god
and a match tonight we shall discover
which young ladies
might succeed at securing a match
i love when all the words come together
no matter what the accent
so brie and matt go on the first one on
one and maybe she should have been
strapped in by her sweater because
they're on these atvs and i
swear i was thinking about how scary and
dangerous
these atvs were i was watching it and i
was thinking it because i don't get on
those myself because they flip very
easily and that's why i'm afraid and
then matt says do you trust me
and then the thing flipped
yeah so he flips it and i was a little
worried but glad to see they were okay
just very muddy very very muddy
oh but luckily this show is the gift
that keeps on giving
and in the middle of the woods we get a
hot tub
so what we have here is a wood-fired hot
tub
and it's not any old hot tub because
it's the first hot tub of the season
and the first hot tub we've had in a
year we didn't have any hot tubs in palm
springs
it was too hot and
this hot tub is familiar yes this hot
tub has
seen some heat before you might remember
it from
jojo fletcher's season of the
bachelorette she and luke pell got in it
after he chopped wood to fuel it and
matt's gonna do the same
here we go nice oh and i missed the hot
tubs you guys i did i love a good hot
tub
and i love a good kiss and brie and matt
have a very good one
even a nice neck caress
just a light defiling in bridgette even
like a kiss is a defiling so that's why
i'm
saying that have you guys watched it yet
a lot of you have i still have the
finale to watch i haven't watched it yet
i've been trying to hold off
let it space out and want to binge it
all in one day different show lauren
not that different though as we
discovered okay but from mud
in our mouths to the mud coming out of
our mouths and victoria is saying things
like
do you not know me i'm like no
do you not know me like uh no victoria
these women don't know you they've just
met you about a day ago so
no they do not uh know you well uh or
even at all
thank you and what was interesting to me
you guys about this
intense comment from victoria did you
notice she seemed to be saying it to a
producer
so that means victoria wasn't even like
putting on an act for on camera
this seems to be how she really really
feels i think she may have to wait for
another season
to find her match penelope is quite
nervous
this will be her very first season but
then back to brie and matt who are
having a lovely dinner conversation
about their upbringings i thought it was
a great chat what did you think of their
date and their connection let me know in
the comments below
and brie gets a rose cheers to that bree
are you gonna accept this rose of course
i absolutely will
i would rather wait for a one-on-one
oh and now back to victoria
victoria was making less and less sense
to me as the episode went on as she says
she can't be her
most authentic self here i don't feel
like i can be my most
authentic self what why say whatever you
want and then she said she wouldn't go
on the group date
i would honestly like not want a group
date based on how
i feel in the group right now but then
she did i don't care do whatever you
want
and by the way don't drink for every
woman
who's on this group date
i think it was 18 names called there's
18 of us on the group date so many
possible matches
for our man i've really got to stop
or do i
picture a quill in this hand has anyone
else read what lady whistle down is
written of late
this is a california style quill
made of the palm bird
i took this from a plant in our lobby
lady whistle down we have 10 minutes to
get dressed
10 minutes all right so we're on the
group date and we are doing a
wedding photo shoot date and when i say
we've done this before
i mean we literally just did this
audacious season of the bachelorette
weeks ago and the same photographer is
even here
look at him yeah you see the wine i
guess they flew this guy from la quinta
i suppose he already had done his
bachelor paperwork so they thought
why bring in someone new but great sure
why not he's fun so they all have to put
on wedding dresses and
a queen victoria said she was the one
having the royal wedding
lost royal wedding oh my god
but i thought she had the least regal
outfit
just me which wedding dress was your
favorite
so just sania went first and went in for
the kiss i'll kiss him and cheers to
that
queen victoria is ready for her big day
oh and then victoria
went in for a kiss but uh matt was not
into that oh my god this
is beautiful did anyone else notice he
was kissing her
with his eyes open
it's uncomfortable to me that was such a
passionate kiss
oh i mean who does a full makeout with
their eyes open
whoa babes coming in hot with a vlog
because i realized on a second watch
that matt
also has his eyes open with other kisses
yes thought it was just victoria but
jasen yeah my case would be nice because
it'll be nice
yeah so i guess it's not about who he
likes or doesn't like because i think
he's into just sunny so
why is he doing that why is he doing
that
let me know in the comments below
why would you do that only if you're
really really not
into it right i think so but let me know
in the comments below need your take
things are about to change chris
harrison is here what's going
on great question what's going on and i
was very
grateful for this this show is the gift
that keeps on giving
we're about to play capture the heart so
basically the women have to literally
run
and capture this giant heart while
wearing the wedding dresses
and throwing paint at each other i was
kind of dying because
this combines uh some very typical
bachelor go-to dates the wedding dress
photo shoot date
and the paints date yes these white
dresses
are mere canvases and the paint the
emotional trauma
smashed into you in a relationship
this team we have the red team is
stacked so we get put on teams and oh
piper is scaring me a little bit because
she's doing like real sports strategy
we're gonna have midfield running
through to get the heart uh she's got
the four words forward they're gonna
play first line of defense
and the backhands like shot my
body against these [ __ ] and
we had been speaking about victoria and
her understanding of words
and she says and i quote i think my team
is a bunch of queens and the other team
is a monster of gestures
do you mean justice gestures
jesters gestures cult
justice gestures gestures
so as a true queen would say let them
eat cake we know the rules don't matter
the winners get time with matt and the
losers don't
ladies on the gold team it's time to
take a moment and
say goodbye is here head on home
one thing i'm loving about filming on
these resort locations and not traveling
is that the losers always have to walk
home now
so they gotta dredge home in these
wedding dresses
that was sad yeah
one of the good way i liked it the gift
keeps on giving
uh now the winners did a little
champagne blast at the end
which i never love because we are
pouring out
good champagne and you know don't pour
one out for every wedding dress wasted
oh and all of the losers are crying i
mean rachel was in tears just sucks
knowing i'm not going on that date
tonight
or was she i couldn't tell she really
looked down
oh and then katie is in tears i've never
been so excited about somebody or was
she
i couldn't tell she really looked down
were they crying let me know in the
comments below
but matt is having some great tearless
conversations he has a wonderful chat
with
lauren i felt like i was a kid again you
know what i mean like i saw a different
side of you i didn't get a chance
and i adored his conversation with
jacenya i definitely dealt with a lot of
infidelity she told him she had been
hurt by people cheating
in the past and that is something that
he said he would
never do do you experience an infidelity
in your relationship
that's not something that i would put
you through wow said it on camera sealed
it with a kiss
cheers to that oh and victoria is
talking to herself pretty much
she's speaking to matt and i'm not sure
how much matt is
uh understanding because what she was
saying certainly didn't make sense to me
she says she is so confident as much as
i come across
confident like i wanted you to know that
like
i'm still a human
is confidence putting other people down
and calling them crazy idiots
you're getting in the morning you're
getting yeah you guys are crazy
and no no no confidence is getting along
with others and building them up around
you because you feel so secure in who
you are victoria
words and definitions
lauren gets the road you accept this
rose yes
of course thank you who are you guys
loving at this point
i really adored abigail in episode one
this episode made me really like brie
and jacenya and lauren
there are lots of great women here huh
so for some reason victoria thought she
was going to get the rose she says maybe
her sharing wasn't enough i shared a lot
and i like
went out of my way during the day so
yeah i was like partially thinking maybe
i'd get the rose
and you know i wanted to take a minute
on this because victoria shared her
insecurities with matt
like picking out a dress today i was
like oh like i hope i don't look fat
or like like i have these thoughts and
i just have to say that telling someone
what you're
insecure about doesn't guarantee a
connection
i also am not sure that i would get into
what i'm insecure about this early on
i'm not saying you shouldn't be open and
honest about who you are but the
beginning conversations feels like a
time to talk about your upbringing
your passions what drives you
right i just think that if you share
your insecurities that early you come
across like you're gonna be
a lot of work for the other person yeah
and while relationships take work
they shouldn't be work do you know what
i'm saying
okay victoria doesn't okay
all right but we've got so many women
here that we better keep going on dates
there's going to be 18 of us there
matt and sarah go on a one-on-one how
are you doing
and i thought i said i could have sworn
i
decreed yes i definitely wrote it down
here
no more planes
no more flying after pilot pete i can't
take it anymore
stay down on the ground
be grounded this is so cute
but finally matt and sarah have their
feet firmly planted
on the grass oh i think that's really
special for sure
and sarah opens up to matt about her dad
having lou gehrig's disease
and how she quit her job to go home and
be a caregiver for him
i came home to san diego
and quit my job reporting and anchoring
and
tv news to be a caregiver and matt's
response to this was interesting
the fact that she should be home with
her pops right now with her family
and she's here with me having dinner
it's an honor what did you think of
their conversation
use your electronic quills and let me
know
in the comments below and sarah gets a
rose
sarah will you accept this rose
of course absolutely and
we get another hot tub it's the gift
that keeps on giving
and you guys you guys
you guys we
even get a fire pit
oh yes yes yes i love a hot tub but you
know i love a hot tub in a cold
environment and a fire pit just
upping the romantic auntie the romantic
lauren that's not a word i don't care
and fill er up it's the cocktail party
welcome and victoria
is continuing to blow my mind
with these word choices
oh she calls herself an empath
i feel like that just goes back to like
me being an empath and if i'm around
that energy
it can sometimes take over no
no i knew
that's all yeah victoria says that she
is an empath which is someone who kind
of soaks up everybody else's energy and
really feels it and if i'm around that
energy
it can sometimes take over because
marilyn has created an and i quote
toxic environment which is unfair to
victoria
just like cries like manipulate
situations
and she's just like straight up toxic
victoria
darling you are the one putting out
the energy okay it was an act
and it worked we got what we wanted what
did you guys think of victoria at this
point
and let me know in the comments below i
actually wrote down
victoria you are as full of it as your
sleeves are full of
air who am i to talk look at me look at
me
a ruffled sleeve always works or does it
in this case i gotta be honest i didn't
know why the bra was hanging out you
guys is that another look i'm unaware of
am i not in on the fashions of 2021 let
me know in the comments below i don't
know
victoria is saying that marilyn said
some stuff but i didn't know what she
was saying marilyn said
and like she just like cries to like
manipulate situations
and marilyn is defending herself i feel
like now i need to defend myself
but i don't know what about and matt is
just as confused he says it's as she
said she says
now it's turned into a she said she said
but i don't even know what was said
ah the escapism drama that we all need
but listen if there was any doubt in
your mind if you wondered if any of it
was editing
here's how we know who is in the right
marilyn
goes to speak to victoria to try to
address things
to attempt to move forward and
don't drink for every time victoria
shuts her down she says
i'm not going outside to talk to you not
going outside it's freezing
we'll give you we'll give you guys a
moment i'm not going to sit next to you
i don't want to sit next to you and my
personal favorite when it comes to
moving forward maturely as an adult to
find compromise
and common ground i don't care we can
come to an understanding i really do
believe that we can if we i
don't care to merely and then she just
walks away
i need a break you're too much for me is
victoria's behavior
regal let me know in the comments below
or maybe as i said maybe it is because
the royal family has plenty of drama on
its own and plenty of
uh rivalries and standoffs and
grudges held i don't know maybe she fit
right in
i don't know perhaps she'd fit
right in and now is the marriage
ceremony
this is what they have been raised and
trained for since birth
i mean the rose ceremony
so things are going well the women are
getting roses
and then sarah goes down oh i don't know
what happened
nobody does jarring camera angles
jarring camera angles
jarring camera angles jarring
camera angles oh and i raised my glass
to this
based on the promo for next week we are
getting more
drama drama drama can you stop no i
won't stop katie i'll do whatever
i want oh everybody what did you think
of this episode of the bachelor i just
dove into it like a
hot tub in the middle of the woods i
loved it let me know in the comments
below i love you guys so much
thank you for watching of course tell
your friends about roses and rose if
they are not watching
yet and you can find me on twitter
instagram tick tock and
cameo lauren zema i love you all
so much and lady whistle down will be
back next week
i was searching for a crown and this is
all i could find good bye